it's done
what is attack hey hey youtubers is
Charlie welcome to my ask emergency for
the Doctor Who Christmas special you all
had a lot of big questions about the
doctors age about Peter Capaldi about
the new regeneration cycle so I thought
it'd be fun to just answer a lot of
those questions in a video so I'm just
gonna read off your questions they
aren't in any particular order but I
condensed a lot of the answers because a
lot of the questions were very similar
number one halo Lego maniac asks when is
series eight debuting so series eight is
going to be a fall 2014 debut they
haven't announced an official date but
it'll either be August or September
number two the red creeper TRC asks how
did the Time Lords move the crack so the
doctor and Tasha LEM talked about how
the covariance exploded the TARDIS and
the doctor rebooted the universe he
basically healed it and when he did that
and left this structural weakness that
was basically where the cracks came from
it's like the universe is like a piece
of tissue paper now and the Time Lords
are just poking holes in it to try and
contact the doctor to try and get
Gallifrey back into the normal universe
so that's all they're doing that's why
it's so easy for them to make cracks and
close cracks question number three full
Dorf Pictures asks when the doctor was
dying in the tower did the Time Lords
grant him another regeneration or twelve
new ones they granted him a whole new
regeneration cycle remember he burned
one to become Peter Capaldi so he has
eleven more now which should last me and
maybe like fifty years but who knows
where the show is gonna be in 50 years
question number four
Bob green wait' asks what did Peter
Capaldi say after he appeared on screen
he said I've got new kidneys I don't
like the color he was referring to
kidneys then he said we're probably
crashing stay calm just focus and then
he looked at Clara and said by the way
do you know how to fly this thing
question number five mirrell co six asks
why does the doctor reserved a new
regeneration cycle and why did they send
him energy through the crack so it's
kind of implied that he got that
regeneration cycle as a result of the
things he did to save Gallifrey during
the 50th anniversary episode he's kind
of like the Han Solo of the Time Lords
they think of him as like this scoundrel
who just flounced the rules but they owe
him big remember because they all died
in the original timeline the reason they
sent the energy through the crack
because the regeneration energy has to
make physical contact with the doctor so
they basically had to send it you know
Time Lord Express mail to the doctor's
mouth question number six dark winter
asks where the Time Lords just waiting
for someone to mention the doctor did
they send him back in time to fix the
cracks or was that Amy's wish that he
went back did Amy send it back in time
so the Time Lords were basically just
waiting for the doctor to say you know
pick up the phone so to speak that was
like all about that joke about the phone
all they needed to do is just
communicate with him and find a way to
bring Gallifrey back that's why they
need his help
so that's basically they're trying to do
they're trying to get him to pick up the
phone during the Big Bang it was
actually Amy that sent the doctor back
they kind of explained that because she
grew up next to that crack in the wall
she basically siphoned off this you know
weird universal energy it wasn't really
explained what type of energy it was but
remember melody pond when she was a
fetus was exposed to the time vortex and
that kind of gave her the Time Lord
abilities that she has so it's not too
much of a jump to think that Amy Pond
gained certain powers from that crack in
the wall although it's kind of implied
that because she doesn't go all bad
Wolf's ever after that one episode that
she lost those powers after the doctor
healed the universe question number
seven danse Lippo asks did the doctor
lose his memory or just parts of it so
you're talking about Peter Capaldi
generally Time Lords are very
disoriented after major regenerations
it's not uncommon for him to just say
temporarily forget things I don't think
he forgot everything but yeah it's
probably gonna take the first couple of
episodes of series eight for him to
completely remember how to fly the
TARDIS there's probably gonna be certain
things that he forgets to question
number eight
Manny Fabian asks does Clara know the
real name of the doctor and is that what
she spoke through the crack is what
you're asking about no she doesn't know
his birth name but remembers the speech
she gave to the Time Lords is basically
the same speech that the doctor gave her
about his name during the series 7
finale he basically says that his birth
name doesn't matter the name that
matters is the name he chose for himself
and that is you know the doctor question
number 9 Michelle slowly asks who is the
woman who played Tasha LEM and why could
she fly the TARDIS
so that was Orla Brady she's not the
same person that played addressed during
the doctor's wife but there are probably
a couple reasons why she can fly the
TARDIS one she's like the leader of the
biggest Church in the universe so she's
probably really smart and it's kind of
implied that she had a sexual
relationship
with the doctor in the past so he
probably taught her at some point
question number 10 the Sherlock de
avatar asks are we looking at another
time war so obviously you're applying if
the time lords come back through the
crack in Gallifrey is there they'll
start fighting again
yes that's Polly is going to happen but
they did not come back in the episode
Gallifrey is still in that pocket
universe but because the Daleks are
still alive if the Time Lords ever do
come back yeah they'll probably start
fighting again but honestly I don't
think the show is going to bring the
Time Lords back for a long long time
question number 11 Joe Joe Allen asks
why did the doctor age during the
episode Time Lords can age just like
William Hartnell basically were
generated because he got too old that
basically is what happened in this
episode they kind of implied that the
doctor was dying because he was so old
about halfway through the episode when
you see him in old-age makeup for the
first time it's been about 300 years by
the time he gets to super old man age at
the very end I would guess that it's at
least another 300 years after that so I
would say he's almost 600 years older
than he was at the beginning of the
episode question number 12
Shelby Larson asks did the doctor get
unlimited regeneration or just one so no
he just got a new regeneration cycle and
like I said he burned one so he
basically has eleven more now even
though it's implied that the Time Lords
can grant new regeneration cycles so
theoretically he could just gain
unlimited regenerations just by getting
new cycles over and over again each time
he regenerates
he gives off more and more energy so
this time you know he said it was a
whopper of a regeneration so by the time
he gets to say like his 24th
regeneration you know he might end up
blowing up an entire galaxy so there are
consequences to regenerating past twelve
question number thirteen BD destro Games
asks why were the silence working with
the doctor obviously a lot of people
were confused because the silence were
trying to kill him during series six
those were a separate sect they were
called the covariance silenced the
normal silence are actually just very
neutral and they followed the orders of
Tasha LEM the head of the church number
fourteen it's just Marie asks how long
was the time wore on trenzalore and
where do these events fall in relation
to the 50th anniversary so like I said
about halfway through the episode he
says three hundred years and then he
ages again like a lot so you know about
six hundred years I would say and in
relation to the 50th anniversary just
going from Clara's timeline she doesn't
really look like she's aged at all so I
would say this is within
at least a couple months of the end of
the events of the 50th anniversary
question number 15
Jake Bamford Ellison asks how do you
feel about the cameo at the end not
being done by the original actress to
play young Amelia pond and what's your
opinion of the Cameo using young and old
amelia and amy so the only reason they
didn't use the original actors to play
amelia is because she's aged about six
years now so that child actor doesn't
look anything like that original Amelia
pond so it would have just been
confusing for viewers overall I felt it
was really nice the doctor the reason
why we saw old Amy Pond is just because
he's remembering her that way but Karen
Gillan was a favorite of mine so I did
really enjoy it number 16 and final
question Jake Adams asks was that
Capaldi's voice speaking the message
through the crack so you're talking
about the you know Doctor Who message
that actually really bugged me at the
episode because no it wasn't Capaldi but
it just kind of implied that it's
someone on the counsel of Time Lords I
did try to find a name for that person
though because I thought there might be
a clue in there so I don't have a better
answer than that right now other than it
was one of the Time Lords
thank you so much everyone for
submitting your questions sorry I
couldn't answer more I didn't want this
to turn into like a 30 minute video I'll
be posting a separate video that'll be a
detailed breakdown of the Kristen
special like my Doctor Who 50th
anniversary Easter egg videos that I'll
probably post tomorrow I still owe you
guys a breakdown of how I think Sherlock
survived the fall so I'll probably do
that video next because I meant to get
that out yesterday so that breakdown or
the Christmas special might end up
posting on Friday morning be sure to
subscribe to get everything
don't forget I'm picking a random
subscriber from the comments below to
just give away another Amazon gift card
I'll be doing that in every video for
the rest of this week too so don't worry
plenty of chances to win right now you
can click here to get my review of the
Christmas special and you can click here
to get my top 5 Doctor Who Christmas
specials obviously not including the
current one thank you so much for
watching everybody get ready for
Sherlock high-fives
you